[موسيقى]
هذا ما تبدو عليه كثير من المعارك في
اوكرانيا طائرات بدون طيار تهاجم مركبات
او تلقي قنابل على مواقع العدو هذه
المسيرات تحمل كاميرات رخيصه الثمن لانها
لا
تعود يتطلب العمل مرونه
[موسيقى]
ودقه يتدرب هؤلاء الجنود على التحكم
بالمسيرات
هذه ليست ذخيره معتاده رجالنا يصنعونها
بانفسهم انها قنبله محليه الصنع ويجب
التعامل معها بحذر شديد نزيل الدبوس وبعد
30 ثانيه تصبح القنبله جاهزه نظرا لاهميه
التحكم بالمسيرات انشا الجيش وحدات خاصه
بذلك سابقا لم يكن لدى الجيش الاوكراني
وحدات متخصصه فقط
الي لا يمكننا الاستناء عنها ل لواء وكته
وحده
كه من
قاعدتهم يتابع هلاء الرجال المعارك
باستخدام مسي خاصه
بالمراقبه
كل هذا ظهر خلال الحرب نستطيع رؤيه ما
يحدث على طول خط
المواجهه هذا جيد نستطيع تحليل سلوك العدو
في جميع الاتجاهات في ورشته يعمل زيات
وشقيقه على تحسين واصلاح الطائرات
المسيره يعمل اخي بشغف على الطائرات
المسيره نشعر احيانا بغصه لاننا نصنعها
بايدينا ثم نرسلها ونعرف انها لن تعود
انها رائعه تبلغ تكلفتها 600 دولار خلال
فتره كانت صناعه الطائرات المسيره
الاوكرانيه متقدمه على الروسيه لكن اختلف
الحال لقد لحقوا بنا وتفوقوا علينا على
الجبهه تمثل طائراتهم الانتحاريه بدون
طيار مشكله كبيره بالنسبه الينا لتجنبها
على رجالنا ترك سياراتهم بعيدا عن مواقعهم
والمشي احيانا لساعات وهذه الطائرات تحوم
فوق رؤوسها
وفقا لمراقبين تنتج روسيا اليوم طائرات
مسيره للمراقبه اكثر بسته اضعاف من
اوكرانيا في هذه الورشه يعرض هذا الجندي
مشكله تقنيه كان موجودا عند جبهه قتال في
احد
القرى لم يتبقى اي مبنى تقريبا نجد فقط
اطلالا لكن لحسن الحظ في كل قريه اوكرانيه
يحفر الناس اقبيه لذلك نحن نعيش تحت الارض
ونقود الطائرات المسيره من هذه الاقبيه
غالبا نذهب الى هناك عندما يحل الظلام
ونغادر
ليلا الطائره المسيره التي قام باصلاحها
هي من انتاج احدى الشركات
الوطنيه من موقعنا راينا مجموعه من قوات
العدو اردنا القاء القنابل عليها لكن
للاسف كان هناك عطل كان الامر محبطا
للغايه ولكن سيتم اصلاحه
الان
يقولون ان بامكان اوكرانيا القيام بعمل
افضل في هذا
المجال هناك العديد من الشركات المصنعه
للطائرات المسيره لكنها ليست متطوره يجب
تنظيم هذا على مستوى الدوله هذا بالضبط ما
تحاول الدوله الاوكرانيه القيام به من
خلال مشروع لاختبار وتمويل الطائرات
المسيره يختبر هؤلاء مدى مقاومه هذه
الطائره المسيره لتشويش
الموجات مساله التشويش م لهذا نقوم
باستمرار بتغير انظمه الاتصالات والترددات
في اوكرانيا انتاج الطائرات المسيره يتم
بالتنسيق بين الدوله والقطاع الخاص
والجيش لا توجد شركه حكوميه تنتج سلسله
كامله نحن نعمل بشكل مختلف ولهذا من الصعب
التفوق علينا نعمل على تحسين منتجاتنا
واستخدام انظمه اتصالات وملاحه مختلفه هذه
ميزه حقيقيه
يوجد في اوكان اكثر من شركه منجه
للطاسه سكايلاب تصنع طائرات بدون طيار
وايضا هذا الجهاز
المتحرك هذا يجنب جنودنا المخاطره
بحياتهم يمكنهم البقاء بامان وارسال هذا
الجهاز لنقل الاسلحه
والذخيره يمكن للجهاز ايضا زرع الغام
مضاده للدبابه
اما بالنسه لهذه الطائره المسيره فينتظر
الحصول على شهاده اعتماد
الدوله نحتاج الى منتج يتم تطويره وانتاجه
بكثره في اوكرانيا الدوله هي وحدها التي
تضمن تطور الشركات اعتقد ان البيروقراطيه
وافرادا معينين يقوضون هذا
الجهد يتزايد انتاج الطائرات بدون طيار
لكنه لا يكفي لتلبيه حاجه اوكرانيا من هذه
المسيرات